[Music]
audiences around the world have been
thrilled by the new Avatar movie but why
was one of its Stars terrified of
returning to Pandora
it was a nine Zoe Saldana appeared in
two movies that would later become the
basis for new franchises JJ Abrams Star
Trek and James Cameron's Avatar perola
zahura spanned three movies and with the
release of 2022's Avatar the way of
water the actress will now settle into
multiple appearances as Navi princess
natiri of course Saldana is also a
long-running player in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with her role as
Gamora a member of the Guardians of the
Galaxy clearly playing a character in a
feature film series is nothing new to
Saldana but natiri in particular is the
one part that took time to return to her
I see you
I see you
many public reactions to Avatar the way
of water are confirming that the 13-year
wait between movies has more than paid
off this marks the longest gap between
franchise character appearances for Zoe
Saldana who filmed all the sequels to
Star Trek and gamora's MCU spots within
a few years of one another in a press
conference during the promotion of the
Avatar sequel the actress spoke candidly
about the strong emotional connections
she shares with her Navi counterpart
Saldana described playing naturi again
as terrifying when something is very
similar to you you can't see it it's
just so close to you that it's not in
front of you natiri and I have lived
parallel lives there's a level of
fearlessness and Rebellion that I have
as a person that nateri had as herself
and we were able to find Kindred in that
in an interview with deadlines Saldana
reiterated some of the talking points
she had shared earlier and discussed the
unique experience of being a misfit
while growing up an experience that
unlocked plenty of bold creative
potential as an adult she also explained
that she can see these qualities and the
director she has worked with including
James Cameron Parenthood in particular
plays a big role in the new Avatar movie
Jake and the two Theory have three
biological children and one adopted
daughter in Kiri love and fear are two
major emotions that come with Parenthood
which Saldana related to her own
experiences with motherhood at the way
of water press conference she said in my
personal life when I became a parent
fear entered my realm the fear of losing
someone that you love so much you spend
a great amount of your time creating
hypothetical scenarios that are just
unimaginable this isn't the first time
the actor has elaborated on these
feelings either in 2019 she told People
magazine as a working mom you live with
that conflict of having to go to work
and wanting to go to work but also
wanting to always be with your children
clearly Saldana's understanding of
natiri's powerful spirits and empathy
fit comfortably with the moving themes
in the Avatar films and it will serve
her well in the movies to come
foreign